today on our show one of us saw the new
Planet of the Apes movie
guess which one find out on this week's
fat man on Batman
[Music]
welcome to Batman Batman I'm Kevin Smith
I'm uh Granard you figure it out yet
huzzah woofer play I saw what for my
lips mark saw it how did you see it
you're out the you're out too [ __ ]
high Spade for business how do you see
it I am out of the newspaper I'm out of
the press business in the same way that
Obama is out of the politics business
which is not really at all still has
friends and the busy pictures you like
[ __ ] hang gliding and totally just
like sheriff fell without a tie places
like just looking like the ex-boyfriend
[ __ ] like wow he looks really good like
I saw a picture recently of him holding
somebody's baby good and that was just
like come back it's like he's the ex
president who still gets invited to the
[ __ ] Buckingham Palace because they
really like him God considering what the
chair works alright so see yes I did you
know people I know a couple people I
asked first the person or two you sought
to get into I start to get into because
I like these Planeta games films
I like this prequel trilogy and you know
not to spoil anything but this is
probably a trilogy yeah yeah ah
actually want to go see yeah it's a
little bit of spoiler but these three
films you know starting with horizon
plan the Apes yes which was James Franco
creating the Planet of the Apes in his
brilliance and beauty means pretty man
right with him I like that that's he
named Caesar and Caesars is budding ah
his eye his small endo father named
Caesar
you know playable in downtown Moscow who
had Alzheimer's and the drug was
supposed to be a cure for Alzheimer's
it was really an attention I told it was
recreated the neural pathways in the
brain so that you could keel parts of
the human brain that had atrophied
according the thanks to Alzheimer's but
in an simian brain it would impart
intelligence it would it would forge new
pathways in addition to the ones already
working supporting speech and killing
stay tuned inductive reasoning plotting
strategy strategy Catedral yes and so
the the chimp who was born as Caesar
his mother was treated with this drug
was it was an original test face
didn't they like at one point like he
opens the gas and they're like and that
made him smoke yeah like is because
Cesar's the first one he's and it's a
wonderful story he's super friggin smart
and and James Franco adopts him because
all of the chimps in this research
facility are going to get exterminated
because it's bad bats we're starting
over takes he's at home raises his AG's
in sign language makes him part of his
house and then Cesar whose ultimate like
a four-year-old kid is violent towards
neighbor they put him in like he get he
doesn't he gets out yeah gets out the
house and like a taxon neighbor for for
banana and James Franco brings him to
that place yes run by Brian Cox and
mouthful II and and yes sprinkle Malfoy
of course and yes and he was sad and he
drew the window that they always looked
out on the wall she'd do Matt Reeves do
that one no no Rupert Everett goober
Wyatt provides of that mana readings in
second one and the third one yeah and
the second one was something like I I
know a lot of people were like a hawk I
love it I love the original plan dates
movies part of my [ __ ] DNA man and
they still hold up today I care what
anybody says maybe not to the effect of
the CG but think about it Roddy McDowall
did all that with rubber on a space with
lipsti didn't move you remember that
look at belt so I love the movies I love
that these movies tie into those movies
but particularly I like that Franklin
quite a bit the last one I like I liked
but I wasn't like as crazy about it I
don't even remember it I remember
there's a damn like I get the day I'm
going and it had the guy who was also in
the Terminator playing John Connor yeah
Jason Clarke yes that's what I meant
here I mean I had one point this fight
on a bridge right with the guerrillas
yeah fighting like jumping at a
helicopter and [ __ ] now that's the first
one really yeah that was the first one
first one is when they were escaping
across the Golden Gate Bridge that
happened at the end of the [ __ ] first
movie yeah first movie is basically it's
a prison break out of San Francisco and
the going I'll head to the California or
they all head to the redwoods that's
right and I remember going the end of
the movie I was like well it's not so
much a Planet of the Apes is the forest
of the agency but then they showed that
cool credit sequence where you see how
see the simian flu
yeah just arcing it sways and not only
is it making ape smarter but it's
killing people
it kills humans unless you want and they
did that and like that's a whole movie
that is a post credit isn't there like
by the way if you're still watching the
credit here's an amazing story by the
way we're killing humanity in the credit
should we do it on camera should we do
on the stage like we've done enough we
gave him James Franco was both smart and
pretty and he had a touching moment
Caesar and Caesar grew and of course
Caesar was played by the great Andy
Serkis
Andy Serkis modern-day Robert De Niro
its Robert she wore green and never
looked like red what could you do to
your mother day lon chaney
if there was actually digital effects
that's probably better there you go good
yeah you're right he is a modern day
launching drink you do that I can call
did anybody ever side that good work I'm
not sure copyright [ __ ] Martin
instead of here a little bit on cab
that's pretty give us their money that's
an excellent analogy right there
so the second movie is it takes place
seven years eight years after the first
one and they got to start the dance and
he's got a kid well yeah I mean Cesar
has built a little monkey Kingdom
welfare like in there tell us when
you're ready
where is the one where he fights the
scar guy that's the second one and the
second we thought you're too soft on she
did the second one I love or because you
know though you do look I do love this
thing I'm not being second one is the
best of the three whoa really yeah
because Gary Oldman is playing this
human guy who's leading the last
remnants of humanity in San Francisco
they just want to build civilization
back they just want to claw back into
the world and they need the power from a
dam that is located in the middle of
Cesar's fiefdom a totally a territory so
they send Jason Clark and Kerri Russell
and a couple of other guys she was in
that movie she's in that movie I gotta
watch this guy I was a bit for that but
it got in my head if somebody was like
what you think of Keri Russell on the
second try on this remake I'd be like
well first of all it's not remake it's
consecutively prequel but second off
from the she was in that the last
thought that would go through my head
before the bullet was baffling mysteries
impacted the Felicity was in budget
planning
remember that and that nothing she's not
a good actress I remember much about the
movie except you were going to a dam the
whole time I was I get there you know
you like that I like it because the the
villain in that movie is Cesar's best
friend and yeah you know Koba who they
they fight in the air if I'm here so
they absolutely were like buddies in the
in the prison circle was mad because
coab is mad because feature is not
extreme enough I saw is that they both
want the same thing they both want to
protect the Apes but Caesar wants to do
it through a path of accommodation and
compromise and acceptance and covers I
can go to the vitamins
let's get guns and so only good human is
are dead you know that's from the
classic in absolutely lives series but
it's it's the origin of a villain out of
brotherhood out of the out of a shared
sense of desire but a fractured sense of
purpose name another story like that
um Star Wars Oh [ __ ] you so smart Ben
Kenobi and Anakin Skywalker excellent
pull yeah you're right
you're my brother Anakin just [ __ ]
legs off anyway balance to the force not
destroy it
man you're legless [ __ ] look at all the
[ __ ] I don't give Anakin look at them I
could help you on again but I won't
because you're a dick Anakin I'm getting
on the plane with your lady and [ __ ]
this noise burn Anakin bird killed over
Anakin
yeah and that's why it was justified yes
I mean what happened I'm trying to
remember my Star Wars so I remember he's
like I have the upper ground and he's
like no I hate your guts he flips over
from your cousin struggle I'm like what
but then diseased arms come off as well
uh yeah look you know he cuts the legs
off and the arms office oh he's just
[ __ ] leg does he cut the arms off
yeah Oh both so he loses both arms and
leg you in one hit he goes from he's
like the brave little tailor seven and
one blow he takes out for we want to
simply jerk to quadriplegic back it's
raining
mine that is
and even at that point so and I remember
he's like I hate Joe while he's burning
Jim but why doesn't does Ben Kenobi
offer to help him or is he just like
that's what you get
I think there's a little bit of [ __ ] you
Anakin like like sorry I'm good with you
forced the issue
good Oh be out
drop the mic over like a burger God give
us to your kid but I that is a weird
scene anyway [ __ ] yeah we stopped to
talk about Planet three so you like
planets to the guys do quite a bit
because the villains storyline is you
physically tied to the hero Christians
didn't edit Anakin Scott well the grand
tragedy of my youth because the Star
Wars movies - fair enough I'll go out of
the Bible right yeah [ __ ] Moses and
Missoula that in the whole look coin
yeah your people all Gordon my people
called me as a commercial for my child
yes I believe who sorry totally sticky
finger I believe that Charlton Heston
has that [ __ ] beat in ten
commandments yes like their brothers and
then totally it's it's it's always been
her that's what I was talking about the
play but it's Ramses and Moses yes
brothers racing up Mary's house who have
different paths towards divine in life
maybe I'm smoking too much weed
I can't separate been her from the ten
commandments and I forgot the other
[ __ ] thing that may be pretty Star
Wars I forgot what literally happened to
his arms and legs but I guess you guys
are writing to the PO pop he's kind of
[ __ ] metal the more I think about
everyone really [ __ ] jumped on his
dick but he's like show me another Star
Wars movie where a [ __ ] takes
off two legs and two arms at once kill
my brother again I go this is George
Lucas come in George's Mac that is kind
of [ __ ] metal and he took off his
legs he [ __ ] loves them there to burn
I would give you a hand Anakin but you
don't have anything here late for niche
I'm going to the desert for the rest of
my life but is gonna be worth it to
watch this [ __ ] oh my god I'll be
talking about this
the next 30 years by the way I'm gonna
raise your son for you tell him you're a
dick I won't talk about this year they
were great pilot or something like that
which you were for a podrace one so
again say that a Jedi named Darth Vader
turned on him and killed him and left
him burning by the side of a lake of
lava he became Darth Vader the way after
that right yeah so I guess like Ben
Kenobi's being metaphorical it's all a
matter of perspective
yeah you ever see that YouTube video
where they show him like Alec Guinness
talked about like you know people make
those videos neat and then put a
romantic song in him and stuff they did
one of those but they you know they
showed him like there's a name I haven't
heard in a long time and they flashed
back to the movie and says basically
done not the lobster but just the like
oh he was talking about this [ __ ] but
like here with the real truth and here's
how he hid it it's very well well done
man well on the Internet are very
creative so by the way back in the late
nineties Planet apes they finally make a
third picture the mega third picture and
it's called battle of the Planet of the
Apes or war [ __ ] see my side of it
better because that's what the last Apes
movie in the last Apes series of movies
was called with a battle and a conquest
conquest of seconds it went planning the
Apes beneath the plan of the ape escape
from the Planet of the Apes conquests
the plan of AIDS battle for the Planet
of the Apes but battle is kind of
battles if you know you're they put
documentaries on the alleged discs and
if you watch them all a guy did devoured
exile of that [ __ ] movies went weird
back in the day start with more money
and their sequels would be made for less
money than $18 so they did had no money
for the last one so but you know even
for even so I remember there's like dune
buggies and they're fighting each other
it's war between humanity and apes and
then at the end there's like [ __ ]
peace like there's a really sweet scene
where they see the statue of the
lawgiver and you see apes and man
together and they talk about like you
know and ever since then apes and man
have been friends and [ __ ] that whole
series if I remember correctly ends on a
note of hope how does this whole series
if it added this prequel trilogy and
only trilogy
um it also ends on a note of hope yeah
not a note of hope that it applies a
harmonious coexistence humans and apes
because again these need to tee up
Planet of the Apes it's true that's
right
diddle so this is now I know they got to
eventually hit the iceberg right
so I we're going to get to a point where
we're going to start talking about
spoilers we're not there yet
but it's clear that it was even clear in
the first movie that this is actually
the story of a of a slave revolt this is
a story of from the first movie from the
first movie to this one it's about
creatures that were in captivity
escaping from captivity sort of trying
to form a easy peace with those who have
been captors who refuse to see them as
humans the fusion see them as beings
worthy of either negotiation or
compassion and then this third one is
about we have to get ultimately it's an
exodus story it's we have to get to the
promised land with Caesar as Moses okay
where is the Promised Land the Promised
Land is much like in Logan it is sort of
implied as just it's that way it's where
no Maps go it's the Forbidden Zone do
they say that ultimately yes they else
they say it's a Forbidden Zone
yeah you just sold a ticket I think you
soul mate take it dies in the end oh
yeah so we're going to get a little bit
into spoiler territory here but spoilers
there's a reference to there's an OVA
character to it the the big push for the
humans is that there is a disease that
even the people who survive the simian
flu there's now some kind of malady
that's sweeping across the human race
that robs people of the power of speech
no oh my god I [ __ ] want to see this
movie so bad man and so quickly I turned
around I'm like Louise but I'm like wait
wait wait revived into the one I want so
yeah so Nova is this first character
that we meet who cannot speak she's a
little girl a little girl question yeah
boilers is that meant to be the Nova
that we meet in place I don't believe so
because I think we still have to go and
400 years
yeah like Taylor has yet to come back
around into like is they launched Taylor
in the first movie you see them launch
the whatever the name of the
[ __ ] shell is dead is it in yeah in
Rise of the Planet Riceville power gates
you see them lost the Icarus drone and
they say it's lost in space they just
mentioned on the news broadcast oh my
god I'm like you're making such a big
family with me
I gotta go back and rewrite yeah and so
like Icarus has yet to land back in in
earth time right so this will not be
that Nova but it's the beginning of the
whole thing would he house in place this
military commander who's decided that he
will not allow he will not truck he will
kill every human encounters who has this
disease lest it be passed on genetically
for a person a person so he's this kind
of Colonel Kurtz II heshes Genesis yeah
he like rather would rather kill those
who would would ruin and harm the gene
pool and allow them to film it and there
be more humans and so at the end of this
movie it is very much about once again
the monkeys get it put into prison
they've got to break out I'll stop you
right there
do 8 o'seas our hails I do not mean to
diminish and degrade our simian brothers
but I feel half of our chief audience
gods like monkeys monkey is a slur we
don't talk about monkey I got yelled at
while we were making mall rats we kept
referring to the ape tango no it wasn't
tango was the one on Jay and Silent Bob
strike back
I have forget what the name of the ape
was that was at the end of mall rat but
we kept saying like was the monkey dude
can the monkey do this and the trainer's
were like sound of monkey monkeys have
tails this is a great ape and I was like
wow my opinions vary but this is Magilla
is this the name of your grade a GE and
the window we get a good will take us
back to the [ __ ] review goddammit we
keep the resident anyway by the end of
this movie the last third of this film
is very much like the lesser of Logan in
that it is about your hero sort of at
the end of his line he's got one last
job which is escort his people to the
promised land
and if you know anything about stories
like this your hero does not get to see
the promised land
yeah Moses never got to go to the land
of milk and honey no Moses never gets
there
Logan never gets to eat
oh it's true you're right Caesar never
gets he gets it he gets to look but
doesn't get to stride spoilers into the
Promised Land and it's it absolutely
gives us sort of fitting closure to this
entire series is that season of the ape
who delivered apes from bondage Caesar
the ape who taught them a new way to
live gave them the rules Apes together
strong if not kill ape knowledge is
power all of that came from Caesar
Caesar delivers them to the promised
land but does not get to enjoy the
fruits of his labor he dies
spoilers well you just put that on Front
Street I kind of did but you know what I
don't care can't spoil a movie for me
especially when you sold it so well
especially when now I know it ties so
well and directly in series I love you
know and so it's it but also we had to
see that coming you have to see it
coming
it's very Shakespearean arc you know I
mean I feel like where this movie sort
of falls down in comparison to the other
ones is that the first movie has been
new it has the yell and war it's back
and they're tying in and holy [ __ ] and
it looks amazing giving you the newness
of Caesar and the realization of what an
ape would look like on the screen in
this way it gives you all those ties
into the original the second one is the
Shakespearean brother versus brother
like who's going to come out on top and
why we're fighting villains all that
stuff right it's like the first one they
can get away with likes [ __ ] new and
it's great movie but like the second one
like oh now we have to Matt's got him a
real movie because they're not going to
give a [ __ ] they're like we've seen the
Apes already like what next so they had
to escalate and it's a ballsy [ __ ]
movie because dawn of the Planet Waves
opens with like 30 minutes of only Apes
on screen and they're talking it's like
a foreign film dawn yeah the foot woman
with Franco's rise so what's down on the
second who's the second one yeah oh when
they've now taken the woods and we're
seeing their way of life and living in
my way yeah yeah
subtitled yeah so you're it's like
you're 30 minutes into a foreign film
before your first unit shows up which is
a ballsy [ __ ] move yeah 40 summer
sequel and pricey because it's a lot of
[ __ ] CG yeah but this movie like wow
good and while it has an emotional
resolution
- it doesn't for me carry the same heft
as the second window the second one is
more tragic
yeah because Caesar wanted peace he
wanted a way to live with him and he
wanted a way to coexist and by the end
of the movie it says there's going to be
war because humans won't allow us not to
have war right like so we had to fight
this war left to win this war and that
tees up war for planets but listen all
of these movies together Oh far better
than they had anyway to be I would I
would agree definitely with the first
one but clearly I don't remember
elements of arrogance up but the version
of the second that you're talking about
sounds [ __ ] dope so I will say
definitely the first picture yeah it is
crazy that this movie works at all
especially on a hardcore fan like me
I'll talk about the first one not the
one that Marc's been reviewing but it
had to pass the [ __ ] taste and sniff
test for an old-school planet Apes fan
and that first movie did yeah in a big
bad way
second one remembers a lot of damn stuff
it's like many times I get mentioned the
word damn damn I said but if you ever
seen a wild effing whether it is it I
watched all of them now I'm gonna in
rapid succession to go outside this is
afarid when does it come out July 14th
so also like this weekend yeah this week
coming up depending on when you listen
to this yeah or it just came out if it
ends up dropping on Saturday which it
might who knows probably then I own
galoshes until it drops and again like
most people I noticed like when we
dropped our spider-man review it wasn't
until like Friday night that all sudden
the numbers start kicking up because
then people like I've seen it too nobody
want me to spoil and I want to know I
want to be able to figure out how I
concur or disagree with what you guys
think so yes go and see it by all means
like it's executed the highest level of
craft and this is the guy Matt Reeves
he's gonna marry the back a Batman next
indeed so this is a dude who knows from
story notion character knows from
conflict and is absolutely willing to go
out and limb to tell you the best story
he can same guys did the Paul Bearer I
come a day of thanks a man I seen yeah
we talked to my dad he did did crazy
deep both deep cuts ah there it is it's
JJ guy run JJ so ginger yeah he did a
clover field yeah that's right yeah
close your [ __ ] dope click alright
there it is man planet e^x was at war
for the planet war for the planet of the
apes go do it
mark says thumbs up thumbs up and I hear
I didn't see it but I'm going thumbs up
based on its description sometimes like
you know the danger that sometimes your
friend describes and moving you're like
a [ __ ] can't wait and then you come
back you know like I didn't see that
movie no you told me a different yeah
that movie you described it's sort of a
big I bet you he's always on poor you
I'm gonna [ __ ] now I know what I'm doing
tonight
there you go I'm literally going to
watch Franco planet eggs I'm gonna watch
that the second one the damn one mmm
powerfully the gangsta my girl I going
to talk about damn again I'll watch the
rest in the morning and then I'm going
to go see the other one in theaters no
one war for the plan of the apes and
then right after that I'm coming home
and I'm watching Charlton Heston nice
you know what I'm saying cuz I did that
with rules all that goes right in
exactly and if I was and if I'm smart I
got it on my phone so when I leave the
theater soon as [ __ ] while I'm sitting
through the credit hoping that there was
their post things yeah you saved me some
[ __ ] say five minutes for me but if I
was going to sit there and [ __ ] I could
sit there and watch I just go right into
watching Planet X there you go see and
maybe the people of theater will stick
around with you and just you all sit in
the theater what are you watching some
other movie and our movie theater I'm
like their log ascend I paid to be here
I'm paying for the space but this is
disruptive like not to me I'll put in
headphones and stuff yeah nobody else is
here it's fine I'm not complaining that
you're showing a movie while I'm sitting
here I paid my money a face alright man
I'm [ __ ] down you see that [ __ ]
tirtir do it all before we go to
comic-con smart comic-con coming up
folks tickets left maybe not by now but
hey wanna see Smaug calm fat man on
Batman we're doing it live we're gonna
do it live not dead God willing oh and
although who could predict the future
but if we can do it dead they better
shoot it could that be amazing okay yeah
look at these two corpses go money in
perpetuity they should be in the ground
but they're still [ __ ] willing to
talk about movie
Josefin new story the weekend they die
oh that's like a Twilight Zone episode
right there I got said chills up my
spine 40 years my Wonder Woman - could
be said to end the Cold War like these
poor dead sons of [ __ ] don't know
that it was about the Cold War they
speculate it was it was good they were
wrong is what the color Wars
Alaba Network Stars that's coming back
it is back definite yeah it's like that
Lagaan show go across networks and no
just within one I think is within one
network because come in the old days
yeah you wanna cross network and they
were like different called shorts like a
DC were like yeah and CBS were blue and
but and also could you imagine if they
were like Battle of the Network Stars
2017 so like you had a Netflix and Hulu
and a [ __ ] ABC them to see Disney
Channel ESPN Syfy uh cord cutters that
would be that's what they'd have to look
out for remember black sunday they
looked out for terrorists with the blimp
mm-hmm do you look at it be looking out
for cord cutters they'd be like the bad
kids just was smoking just wow we
supposed to battle other network stars
if you're going to keep cutting a [ __ ]
cord like by app channels OTT a piece of
[ __ ] the futures here CBS all access
vision commercial right no yeah just
hopefully any other which like a
navigable ass comes a comic on so we
could talk about networks makin some
obscure inside network jokes and [ __ ]
that only like low-level people working
at the network could even find mildly
amusing like ah
okay that wouldn't be kind of funny
don't pitch it uh-huh like wow that's
even funnier than what we said there's
that chance to see us and then the
funding fest which is in Canada and King
John in the end of August at the end of
August mango the tickets want tickets go
to tickets at see Smaug calm yes come on
see us there it is man yes he saw war
four five eggs you should too and I'm
gonna knock me on Batman
Kevin Smith I am mark Barnard come back
next week we've done good work here
we'll talk about yeah I think we've done
to try and work here yeah peace love
unity
I've been Kevin and I've been working
hard tune in next time same bat-time
same bat-channel [ __ ] baton on that roof
do the house okay I'm gonna get sued by
one Rose SModcast calm or youtube.com
slash Kevin Smith
[Music]